[Music]
this is star talk cosmic queries edition
of course i got check nice with me to
make this happen check what's up neil
dude you know it's not it's not often we
get one of my own people that's right
and a cosmic queries that's right just
just my my kindred
spirit
and today
we've got professor hair dr brian cox
across the pond from the uk brian
welcome to star talk dude not your first
rodeo with us
no it isn't no we've been doing this for
a few years now yeah 10 years ago i've
been a guest on europe on your show
a couple of times i've been in the uk i
was there live you got an audience and
stuff so that that was fun and so you
let me get your make sure i get your bio
accurately described here you're a
professor of particle physics university
of manchester that sounds very specific
it's not you're not just professor of
physics right
yeah
physics yeah i mean my my research
history was i worked i've worked at the
particle accelerators around the world
actually including fermi lab in chicago
daisy in hamburg and cern in geneva so
that's yeah the big ones
okay and so out of the uk you've hosted
multiple tv shows uh the one i remember
most is the universe and you also did
one on the solar system correct correct
me if i'm wrong
assistant and uh that was the local
version of that travel show
yeah yeah this is the bit that we might
be the greater travel show was the
universe and you were like by the way
check out this neighborhood
yeah
we're gonna do multiverse next and
you've got another one the brian cox's
adventures in space and time
and
uh for me what's most important is that
you have come
stateside you have crossed
you've crossed the ocean
to give a multi-city
stage theater tour
of the universe this is this is
bold hairy and audacious i love it i
love it and by the time this posts uh
you're in the middle of the tour uh
coming up in edmonton and canada
edmondson calgary vancouver and then you
slip down into seattle portland can't
not do them if you're doing canada right
and then sacramento san francisco san
jose los angeles two nights in los
angeles san diego then you hit up texas
and it sounds like a johnny cash song
i'm not touched
i've been ever aware man
and you end it in texas
in houston texas
so
good luck with that tour oh my gosh what
can people expect
well it's um it's spectacular is the
first thing to say so we use the biggest
led screen that we can fit into the
venues it was designed actually for the
in the fall we're doing these huge shows
in the in the uk because i i always say
to you you know people know who i am in
the uk and it's a bit more a bit more
low-key in the
and so the the show is designed for 15
000 seat arenas and so we produce these
graphics of flying into black holes a
lot of black holes in there
considering the uh the nature of life in
the universe origin of life future of
life the multiverse so all the big
questions in space time black gold
cosmology but it's essentially big
graphics and um hopefully for everybody
i mean i do do some
complicated stuff in the middle about
quantum entanglement and the black hole
information paradox that we can talk
about later but um the idea is of course
it wouldn't be a show unless you did
that right right of course duh i was
talking it out with my uh eight-year-old
last night
it's on the tip of everybody's telling
me it is you know i was like sweetie now
just remember uh you know in the morning
we'll finish this little conversation on
quantum entanglement in the meantime
sleep here but not here in l.a
[Laughter]
so you've so this is this is not
a brian cox lecture on stage this is a
performance
with a hugely
um a hugely visually
uh delivered
messaging about science and physics in
the universe and yeah
and uh there's a music's a big part of
it so it starts with um
sibelius's fifth symphony the third
movement and uh almost a version of 2001
that i ended up making because i'd asked
a friend of mine he's a conductor as a
joke one night you know what said what
should stanley kubrick have used right
and he was kind of a joke but he
immediately said he should have chosen
this piece of music by sibelius which
was written in 1915 and it's at one
level it's about swans taking off from a
lake in northern finland
but at another level it's about the deep
beauty of nature it's that idea that
famous quote from einstein that if you
look carefully at nature you might catch
a glimpse of something deeply hidden
which is the structure of nature itself
and so that it just sounded like that to
me so i ended up um almost remaking 2001
in eight minutes
to the horror of my promoter so let me
quantify i pay for it how
popular
you are in the uk i have i have a way to
measure that for you i don't know if i
ever told you this okay so
okay
so right now
in the united states
i i'd be stopped by 15 out of 20 people
in the street okay because they'd
recognize me whatever okay i think for
you it's 20 out of 20
or 21 out of 20 people in
in the uk but i can quantify that okay
you are so popular there
that no one knows who the hell i am
there so watch what happened we were
filming
cosmos
we're in trafalgar square big square and
we're filming cosmos and we're cordoned
off okay
and all and i'm there you know
delivering lines and things and all
manner of people hey that's neil
degrasse i said oh where are you from oh
we're from the netherlands oh we're from
india uh we're from russia oh we're from
stopped who was from the uk
nobody
so either they're just polite and they
don't
or
you completely occupy that space
in the uk and that's what i'm thinking
is going on or brian does all of his
talks in the uk and instead of ending it
with keep looking up he ends it with
don't listen to neil degrasse tyson
i'm totally happy okay just to swap for
a few months so i'll you can have the uk
i'll have the us
just until the end of this tour we'll
we'll swap rolls that's good
good deal for me so no no i don't here's
the question i can't even recite this
many cities in the uk that you're going
to do here in the united states this you
know this feels like a little bit
because you got that beatles haircut it
feels a little bit like the british
invasion you know putting us in a new
place that we didn't even know we could
land nothing wrong with that yeah
nothing wrong with that very cool
so chuck you you collected questions
from our patreon supporters indeed we do
have them
and uh of course you know our our
listeners very excited
uh to ask brian questions so do you want
to jump into this yeah let's go straight
ahead what do you have all right this is
uh
marcus
gustafsson
gustafson who says
hello and greetings from sweden if the
strength of gravity happened to be a
little stronger or a little bit weaker
than it is
how different
would our universe be
it's a good question and it's this is
widely debated actually because um
there's a question of how much you can
change the the fundamental properties of
nature so do you say the strength of
gravity the mass of the electron the way
the higgs field works all those things
such that you have a radically different
universe and actually it's quite hard
because you can change some things and
then change something else and it kind
of balances the change out and and so
it's quite a controversial area actually
but
broadly speaking if gravity were too
strong
all else being equal
then things would collapse ultimately
into black holes very quickly so the
early universe would not have formed
extended structures like galaxies and
solar systems
stars may be very short-lived and and so
on so you can change you can change the
universe such that you would not have
life in the universe if you increase the
strength of gravity too much but also
you can decrease it too much and then
stars and galaxies don't form in the
early universe and again
you probably don't have a living
universe now you could the complication
comes when you say okay well what if in
the early universe the the slightly over
dense regions
were a bit denser which would have
something to do with
a theory we called inflation possibly or
something that you know the way the big
bang was and then you turn gravity down
a bit can you kind of compensate and
it's true you can so it becomes an
extremely difficult modeling challenge
and so you'll see research papers on
this how can you change the things and
fine-tune things but then broadly
speaking that's what happens if it is
too strong then everything collapses
into black holes and it is too weak
nothing forms at all
so that's the phys that's the physicist
answer okay now we'll give you the
astrophysicist's answer
all right in
in graduate astrophysics 101 okay
one of the first calculations we do is
what happens to the luminosity of a star
if you change the gravitational constant
okay it's a calculation we do
all right so you what you do is you you
put a little parameter there and see
what happens to that parameter as you
run through the calculations for a
star's luminosity and what you find
is that the luminosity of a star is
extremely sensitive
to the value of newton's gravitational
constant to the seventh power wow okay
so
so what's interesting about that is
if the gravitational constant were
different
slightly higher earlier in the universe
than today as as as brian can attest
there are whole branches of physics that
think about and wonder and worry about
whether the constants have actually been
constant all right but forget whether we
can we have god-like powers to just
change it and see what happens were they
always this great did they change over
time so you can look at what how
sensitive it is and constrain
how much it could have possibly changed
because you would see stars of enormous
luminosities living out their lives very
quickly in the early universe and you
don't see that
so
it's to the seventh power of that
term that the luminosity would be
affected and seventh power is it's that
times that times that times that times
that okay all through so we actually
find that number uh in intro
astrophysics graduate school and can you
define luminosity for me it's not
because if you're saying that it's it's
not just brightness it can't oh yeah
yeah so here it is right simple if this
this this example is rapidly becoming
obsolete but take 100 watt light bulb
okay yeah well yeah
okay what is that right okay exactly in
the old days it was like these that's
like okay now here's what you do first
uh you dial up your grandmother on a
rotary phone
so
so the wattage is its luminosity so no
matter what distance i put it from you
it will always be 100 watt bulb okay
gotcha
as i get it farther away it gets dimmer
and dimmer dimmer so that would be its
brightness right that's all so that's it
so okay so you're saying that gravity is
like a string on that on that uh on the
light itself kind of like that would be
making it less no no it would be like a
knob like a knob turning it down
thank you right yeah yeah so instead of
pulling it back it's turning down a lot
okay that's cool man yeah yeah it's a
dimmer it's a dead thing on the right on
the bulb itself yeah let's make the
universe sexy baby you know
let's dim the lights hey you know
how would you like a little cosmic
champagne
all right next time to go to the next
question
i'm enjoying this
you like the sexy universe brian
[Laughter]
i'm gonna use some i'm making notes
all right let's go to uh
sandra
bayani and sandra says is it possible
that the laws of physics change beyond
our cosmic horizon so that all of our
theories about multiverses stop working
and stop making sense greetings fellow
earthling i cannot get enough of this
show please whatever you do
never stop this podcast oh
chuck did you just had that no i did
i really
i mean i loved that question yeah that's
a wonderful i love that quote because it
brings in our horizon and multiverses
and the very theories that predict a
multiverse work in our universe why
should they work in another we're going
to take a break and when we come back we
will get right to the heart of that
question with our special guest today
he's a special guest to me brian cox
from over in the uk we'll be right back
we're back star talk cosmic queries this
is everything physics because i got one
of my people here
one of my one of my uh science and
education brethren brian cox from over
in the uk
who
uh they call him a rock star over there
and we've said this on his previous
appearances but it's worth
repeating
that this man had a number one song on
the pop charts in the uk
so you're literal and figurative rock
star of science am i have i overstated
that brian i think no i think you've
understated it if anything
so what's the name of the song again
that you performed the most famous song
is a song called things can only get
better which you will say correctly is
again it runs a counter to the second
law of thermodynamics
so it's an inaccurate song but uh yeah
yeah sometimes you gotta break some eggs
to make an omelet you know as they say
all right so chuck we left off with a
brilliant question about here we are in
our universe that has our own horizon
and we come up with our own theories of
the universe and one of them is that
there might be a multiverse so beyond
our horizon if it's not in our universe
why should we even believe that the
rules that predict a multiverse would
even exist there you go i love that
there's a lot to unpick there um so our
horizon first of all that there is a
limit to how far we can see um which is
the fact that our universe is of a
finite age or let's say there's been
13.8 billion years since the big bang
and so there's a there's a finite
distance you can see because light
travels at a finite speed so we are very
sure that there are galaxies way beyond
our horizon but essentially the light
has not had time to reach us from them
and now actually neil said in the la the
answer to the last question um you can
ask that you can say well
observationally do we see any evidence
of the laws of nature so the strength of
gravity for example going back to the
last question
changing as we look out to the most
distant galaxies and the answer is no
we have no evidence that they change in
the patch of the universe we can see so
that's the observational point um but
when you start to talk about the laws of
nature in different regions of the
universe or multiverse as you said
then it becomes more interesting um
one multiverse there are lots of
different kinds of multiverse but one of
them is called the inflationary
multiverse so we have a theory called
eternal inflation which essentially
leads to the idea that there are perhaps
an infinite number of um bubble
universes of which ours is one and the
piece that we can see the observational
the the little piece we can observe is a
patch in one bubble universe amongst
perhaps an infinite number of bubble
universes in the inflationary multiverse
and those theories do lend themselves
potentially
to to the laws of nature in each bubble
possibly being different and the way i
sometimes picture it is like a snowstorm
with snowflakes so every snowflake is
different
because it's had a different formation
history
but there's something similar about the
mole which goes to the underlying
structure which is to do with the water
molecule itself so there's something
similar there's an underlying framework
but every snowflake is different and the
inflationary multiverse can be like that
so you can imagine that the laws we see
things like the strength of gravity
so crystallize out as these bubble
universes form from the
the the potential which is the
this thing called inflation that's
potentially going on all the time so so
it's possible that different universes
have different
um emergent laws things like the
strength of gravity and we i think
most physicists probably all expect that
there'll be some kind of underlying
framework
which could something that we don't know
what it is right something like string
theory or something
which underlies the whole thing and so
that
maybe neil wants to add but that's the
my summary of the inflationary
multiverse i love your snowflake analogy
but
suppose
that
do you have enough latitude in your
eternal inflation inflationary
multiverse model
to have a universe that has five pointed
snowflakes instead of six i mean is how
much room do you have to just
make stuff up
completely
we don't know this goes back to it links
to something called the string landscape
which leonard suskind actually wrote a
great book called the cosmic landscape a
while ago detailing this theory so when
you look at strings just remind me
leonard is the one who's a big exponent
of the holographic universe that's the
same guy yeah he's one of the he's been
at the cutting edge of physics for
decades raising and then so
in the string landscape the idea is that
um
in string theory it turns out you can
have there's a number that they
calculate i don't know how they do it
actually it's something well i do know
how they do it it's something to do with
all the extra dimensions being curled up
and stuff it doesn't matter but
essentially 10 to the power 500
different possibilities
so one with 500 knots after it these are
the different ways that you can produce
um laws of physics like the ones we see
from the underlying theory and that was
seen as a really difficult wiggle room
right there well it was it but but the
way i see it it's almost like saying we
understand dna so in biology we have a
theory we have these things a c d
t and g right the four different bases
that come together to form dna
and it's like saying okay so there's an
underlying theory it's pretty simple
it's the double helix it's chemistry
out of that it's like saying right
predict a human being
so of course you can't because there are
many different combinations of dna and
we have no understanding yet of which
ones would work and which ones wouldn't
and which ones can be realized by
evolution and which ones can't you know
it's just it's an astronomical number of
combinations
of just to make humans let alone all
forms of light so it's like saying we
understand the basic chemistry that
gives us that thing dna
but then from that predicting a
particular instance of that an organism
is of course it depends on its history
it depends on all sorts of things and
it's it's the same if you look at that
like um
i don't know an alphabet to create a
language
um can you rule out the nonsense for
instance if you know english you know
that uh hlp pp5
is not a word
[Laughter]
right
so are you able to kind of rule out the
nonsense
that okay these things
would not happen and so
even though it is a possible combination
we know that it's kind of gibberish how
do we
narrow that
well i mean we don't i mean we don't
know we haven't got the expertise we
don't really know what the underlying
theory is um but i mean for example you
could imagine a bubble universe that
forms and gravity is so strong
that it just collapses again in a
millisecond there may be many universes
like that so that might be
you know as you say that might be a
universe that we consider was just never
got going
so it might just about form and then
collapse again for example you'll know
you'll know if you made a life form from
there because it's just like that
yeah
[Laughter]
not only are the laws of physics
gibberish so is their language that's
what you're saying i mean i just want to
emphasize what i'm saying this is
speculative stuff so the string
landscape as i said lender suskin's book
is great on this uh and then the link
though it's interesting the inflation
which neil will know about as well
that's a theory that was introduced
initially just to
deal with something called the horizon
problem you mentioned the horizon it's
essentially the the unexplained point
that if you look out
look in one direction out into the
universe as far as you can and then turn
around and look in the other direction
then you're looking at points that
emitted light that we're receiving now
that now
in the universe is something like 93
billion i think it is light years away
right because the expansion of the
universe so you're looking at points
that in the standard model of things
could never have been in contact with
each other and yet are at the same
temperature so one part in a hundred
thousand which is an observation
interesting so that means an
inflammation
chuck i think we did an explainer on
this yeah
there was something where i was talking
about uh yeah the universe has
has a more uniform temperature right
then different parts of the same room
you're in right well that's because we
were with that explainer we were talking
about redshifting is kind of how we got
into it oh that's how we got there
because i was saying you have a air
conditioner in a corner you have a
heater over there right and you're fine
if it's a five degree range in a room
that's talking to itself
thermodynamically yeah and now we have
across the whole freaking universe and
it's when it's within a hundred
thousandth of a degree which is
completely mind-boggling freaky and we
needed a freaky explanation for it yeah
so inflation was the idea that once upon
a time they were in contact and then the
universe expanded very very very very
fast for us for
probably a small amount of time um and
so and so we thought that they couldn't
have been in contact with with each
other but in fact they were and so
that's why inflation was introduced but
it ended up it ended up doing several
things that it was not designed to do
initially one was that the thing that
drives inflation which has got a fancy
name called the influence
it doesn't matter it's a breakdown in
the supply chain that's yes
oh it makes that look trivial
two points were doubling in this if you
take the two points in the universe then
they double the distance between them
doubled every 10 to the minus 37 seconds
in the the basic models of inflation so
it's much worse than we're going through
now with prices it's an incred
exponential expansion
but much worse just an understatement
there just to be yeah yeah but in
looking at that um
stephen hawking actually was involved in
this and many physicists in the 80s
found that these just said chuck chuck
last time we did this he said stephen
he's cleaning it up this time he's clear
he's he's
he's been a little better
i named draw we got to hear the last
name here stephen kitt lenny all those
people
so
so that that theory it was discovered
predicted that there would be ripples
in the density of particles in the
universe through the big bang as
inflation drew to a close which are the
ripples that we see in the cosmic
microwave background radiation which you
may have talked about and also actually
in the distribution of galaxies across
the sky
so there's a distribution they're not
just completely random across the sky
there are patterns in the galactic
distribution
and that was predicted before it was
observed by this theory so the theory is
interesting and textbook but you'll find
it in cosmology textbooks but the
eternal inflation bit which is kind of
an add-on to that ends up with this idea
that inflation doesn't stop everywhere
at the same time basically so you get
multiple bubble universes
and then that theory it was noticed that
that's a mechanism to realize the string
landscape which gives you the
possibility of varying the laws of
nature in each of those bubbles so that
was the history so it's not just it
sounds fantastical but it's not just
like somebody just dreamt it up one day
and said this would be i try to make
that clear
otherwise they think we're just pulling
stuff out of our ass and it's it's uh
even if it is out of our ass it's very
carefully withdrawn
by the way that's uh that's one of the
universes
with a central black hole yeah time to
go to the next question oh no no really
we need to move on oh okay okay here we
go
kitty wagons
uh says this hello dr tyson dr cox and
lord nice
and i bet you can't pronounce my name
correctly
you win that bet all right
get no argument from me
i would say
h-i-d-d-e
uh w-a-a-g-e-m-a-n-s
i said hidy wigmans
uh and he's from the netherlands so he's
dutch
um
he says i'm asking myself after i
watched the movie the atom project
if you really can time travel with
wormholes
by the way oh here we go uh chuck hidy
is pronounced hidden
without the n
who knew well
there you go
yeah okay well you gotta reach to the
end so you can help you pronounce it
people help you out there that is too
much work neil
all right so so so brian we're talking
about time travel and wormholes uh i
presume we i think everyone knows with
einstein relativity you can travel into
a future all right or at least into the
future of where you once were so let's
confine this to can you go backwards in
time do wormholes enable this at all
wormholes are getting increasingly
interesting actually and particularly in
the study of black holes we can get onto
that but um so yes wormholes are allowed
geometries in einstein's theory general
relativity if you just take that theory
alone what do i mean by that so they
really are shortcuts through space and
time so you can imagine you're traveling
from new york to sydney it takes a long
time you go around the surface of the
earth or you could tunnel through and
you could get there quicker so so yes if
wormholes exist and you could travel
through them and they were big enough
and stable enough
then you can build a time machine and
now
virtually every physicist who works on
this and kip thorne actually who got
nobel prize for gravitational waves did
quite a lot of interesting work on this
um it looks like he was the main advisor
in the movie interstellar he was in fact
an executive producer which and the
robot in that movie was named kip it was
and he has a worm for that yeah so and
he also actually suggested to carl sagan
in contact that wormholes were used
in the movie content
so
when you add quantum mechanics into the
mix which is the theory of everything
else because our universe hasn't just
got gravity in it it's got all sorts of
other things in it as well obviously
atoms and electromagnetic radiation and
so on
then it seems like the wormholes are
inherently unstable the big ones and if
you try to travel through one it
collapses so that's basically i should
say by the way that they're part they're
such an integral part of einstein's
theory it's a very famous play for the
1930s by einstein and rosen
and they they were called einstein rose
and bridges before they were wormholes
and they're they're built in to the
basic description of a black hole if the
black hole had listed lives forever it's
called the it's a the maximally extended
swatch chilled metric right whatever
it's called but that which was
discovered by schwarzschild in 1916
just after the theory was published then
there's a wormhole in there right so
they're just fundamental to the theory
but most physicists believe and stephen
hawking wrote a paper actually called
the chronology protection conjecture
conjecture where he thought about this
who knew he was a rapper they will be
unstable
yeah
i can even say you can say i can't say
it chronology protection conjecture um
but
that these things would not be stable
and you can't travel through them so you
can't build time machines however
it's worth saying that wormholes are
becoming very very fashionable now in
what's called the er equals epr
paradigm so einstein rose and er is
einstein rosen this thing from the 1930s
where einstein and rosen noticed that
they these geometries exist in space
time or can exist epr is einstein
podolski and rosen spooky action at a
distance it's quantum entanglement
and so what now is very fashionable and
looks it's one of the best explanations
of how information gets out of a black
hole is that this plays a role so you
can there's a kind of a dual description
so we've got quantum entanglement which
is this spooky action at a distance
thing where you separate things to large
distances and they're still
linked in some way
the linked in some way is starting to
look possibly like you can describe that
in terms of wormholes
microscopic wormholes linking them
together but this is really this is
stuff that's been done now 2020 2022. so
it's um it's on the edge but people are
taking it okay so wait let's let's pause
there and come back but all right now
you've established that we agree we can
think about wormholes but you haven't
told us how to go backwards in time when
we come back brian cox is going to tell
you how to go back and not kill your
parents
okay and i could tell you an even
simpler way if you really want to go
backwards in time get married and do
something wrong because she will never
let you forget
thank you chuck for your marital put
splitting your marital issues into this
podcast
star talk will return with brian cox i'm
going to find out how to go back in time
be there
we're back star talk costume queries got
chuck of course chuck you're uh tweeting
at chuck nice comic thank you sir all
right you got some fun stuff there that
tracks current events and things so it's
always good to see what you have to say
about that and brian cox my friend and
colleague from the uk is uh taking the
united states by storm and a little bit
of canada in a mult dozens of cities
he's bringing his major theatrical
production of do you give it a title or
is it just everything you want to know
about where we are in the universe how
about that like horizons horizons there
it is yeah
that's that's billy connell is over that
way no which way okay
and brian cox you can find his schedule
and brian cox live
dot
co dot uk uh just do a google on branch
live it'll send you there and you can
see the whole schedule and he's coming
through town with a hugely visually
spectacular display
and this is what you know
this is what stages are for if the
universe is the biggest stage of them
all
he's brought the universe
onto into theaters so brian welcome to
town for this wow so we left off with uh
describing wormholes and i have to tell
the story just
brian i have to tell this okay
chuck so brian you just stay on the side
while i tell this to chuck so chuck i'm
in i'm in london and i'm a guest on
brian's show okay we're talking about
space travel and space exploration and
uh and he's got a whole audience there
they're all uk people okay and they're
kind of i'm they're new to me and i'm a
little new to them but they know brian
but and they know i'm american so i talk
about the future of space travel and i
say
maybe you know no chemical rockets are
not going to work in order to do this we
need like warp drives or ideally
wormholes and then we can do this and
brian kicks in and said wormholes are
unstable and they'll collapse and you
can't do this
he's correct but that's not the point
the point was the audience do you
remember what the audience said the
audience said
that's why the americans discover
everything
yeah they're so optimistic about
everything that's why they went to the
moon and we're stuck here in london and
so you lost your audience on that
comment brian and i had them from there
because they liked my american uh some
of it was just me but then i realized a
lot of is just american enthusiasm
you know so so brian how do you use
wormholes to actually travel backwards
in time is that possible well so
yeah if if if they were stable
or you could stabilize them in some way
then you could use them as time machines
um and uh that's
considered
to be unlikely
um
but it it really is true to say that we
well it's very true to say we don't have
what's called a quantum theory of
gravity so we don't really
in any sense understand the the deep
merger between relativity and quantum
mechanics which you need to understand
to answer that question and many
physicists point out that we don't you
know it feels like it's no way to build
the universe we've all seen back to the
future we all know the paradoxes that
happen if you time travel is a reality
so so i think if you pushed most
physicists and said don't be formal
about it and don't say what i just said
which is we don't understand quantum
gravity yet um
then most physicists would say okay we
think the laws of nature will be such
that there aren't stable
macroscopic big wormholes
and that's what i think most physicists
would say
but actually you mentioned interstellar
um and kip thorne is one of the world
experts on this does point out that you
can get around this so you could have a
universe uh which permitted time travel
and was not full of contradictions if
there were no free will at all
so the whole universe itself
is completely consistent
and the time travel is built into the
consistency so that's a and that's
actually what you see in interstellar
so that that happens in the plot of
interstellar he can't stop it i'm not
spoilers you know but he can't stop
himself leaving his daughter's room in
the future and by the way that's that's
also what happened in the story
slaughterhouse five by kurt vonnegut
which is a time travel story on top of
being a world war ii story but
his as and i think kurt vonnegut got it
right uh correct me if i'm wrong brian
he just described your life is always
there you're always being born you're
always dying you're always in school
you're always in love and you just
rejoin where you were on that timeline
and relive that there's a stephen
hawking's
birthday party no it's kip thorne's
birthday parties there's a proceeding so
neil and i when we have scientific
conferences you have a proceedings it's
a big thing and there's a proceedings
i think it's kit
i think it's his 60th birthday party and
stephen hawking gave her a talk and it's
written up in the proceedings of his
birthday party because he's so eminent
and stephen said um said that kip has
become increasingly interested in time
travel through wormholes as he's got
older
that's how he started
that's good
that's good that's good i i checked this
out
third of three segments uh give me give
me a few see if you can slip in a few
more questions all right here we go this
is catherine celerini mora who says dr
tyson dr cox lord nice hoping that you
can hear dr cops elaborate on he alluded
to in his youtube video regarding time
and space not being the stuff from which
everything else is derived rather that
time and space may be derivative of
something much bigger
much deeper deeper
this comes from the uh
the study of black holes um primarily
and the the i would say it looks like
space and time emerge from quantum
entanglement so we mentioned
entanglement right before i should say
what it is should i say what it is
should i give the one minute
introduction to them sure sure so so
imagine you have a
coin and you can toss it and it can come
up heads and tails and if it was a
quantum coin and there's two of them
they can be in what we call a state
such that you could separate these coins
out across the milky way to the edges of
the universe
and you just look at one of them and you
could toss it and it would be heads and
tails obviously you can look at it in
its heads you look at it again it's
tails 50 of the time looks completely
normal
but actually if you got back together
after doing lots of experiments on this
thing you would find that the coins
never came up heads at the same time or
tails at the same time they're always
head to tails plus tails heads or heads
tails or tail centre right they're
always opposite so you can build a
quantum state like that that's called
entanglement so it's an interesting
thing it's kind of um
it's like the information all the
information contained in this system of
two coins is somehow spread between them
and they don't behave as individual
entities even if you separate them to
vast distances so that's entanglement
because they're not just coins they're
also waves and the waves
know about each other outside of the
local place where the corners getting
flipped no it's it's that's the truth
then i've been saying it wrong all these
years no no they um they
really they are the best way to consider
it is it's a it's a single system
and the information the structure of the
system is approximately the whole thing
why isn't that the best way to think
about it that's got to be the wave
function oh it is the weight yeah so
the wave function you'd write it down
it'd be a heads tails plus tails heads
is an example of a wave function and for
the for the geeks there we can have a
one over root two there we go in front
of each one everyone equal problems
you've gone too far
the key point is
it's it's it's sick you had me at wave
you lost me at one over root
so that's an entangled system and
deep in there is that the the there's a
term that's squared in the wave function
so he's got to put the square root of
two so that when you square that it's
becomes a half yeah if i wanted the 50
50.
there was a missing piece of what he was
saying there yeah okay it's the
amplitude right
so um so that's entanglement it's a
fundamentally quantum mechanical thing
and it's very well understood and we use
it in technology and quantum
cryptography and so on so it's a thing
this is how the universe works
and it does seem as if um as i mentioned
before the idea that you can also
interpret that as having wormholes
connecting these things together i love
it essentially what you're seeing is
that entanglement and space are
intimately related
and that's the the modern way of looking
at this the very modern way and uh i i i
think it's fair to say that most
physicists would say that the
entanglement is the fundamental thing
and so we're beginning to think now
that you have a theory of quantum
mechanics quantum field theories um on
some surface or something and then the
entanglement actually it produces the
space i mean it's true to say that
entanglement i've seen it said which is
a beautiful thing to say that
entanglement is sort of the glue that
keeps space together
and so entanglement it seems is
fundamentally related to space
and therefore
time but it's more more obscure so
that's the next sci-fi frontier because
uh the latest
doctor strange is
madness through the multiverse or
something so they got the multiverse in
there and he's opening up portals which
are basically wormholes as he
you know jiggles his hand so now we got
to somehow get down into the very fabric
of the space and time itself that would
be good all right cool chuck we got just
a couple see if we can go into like uh
lightning mode like if we can okay uh
let's lighten things up here with uh
lindal freeze who says dr tyson dr dr
cox uh chuck here is uh is there a
parameter edge of the universe and where
in relation to that edge is the earth or
the milky way located are we closer or
farther to the center of the universe
also how do we know the universe is
expanding and is it just that our
instruments are getting stronger
much like okay so we need that in a
sound bite
i can do it
so no we're not at the central universe
we're at the center of the observable
universe because that's just a piece
that we can see right but um the
universe extends way beyond that horizon
and uh so it could be infinite an extent
but we don't know so um but it's much
bigger i think than the piece we can see
so no we're not at the center of the
universe it might be an infinite
universe and we know it's expanding just
very simply because we look at light
from distant objects and that light is
stretched
and the the the uh the explanation is
that you light is a wave and it's
traveling through expanding space
and so it gets stretched as it journeys
and what the the basic observation all
the way back to hubble is that the
further away the perceived the person
edward right yeah yeah all the way back
the the further away the thing is the
more the light is stretched when it
reaches us and that's what you would
expect if space were expanding um
essentially a uniform rate it's actually
changing a bit it's expanding a bit
faster now okay so there is no so if we
went if we said i want to go to my
horizon let's chuck let's leave tomorrow
yes so then what would we see
you'd see the same universe as far as we
know so you could go to the horizon
um and uh look around and you'd see
a completely uniform universe with the
same kind of distribution of galaxies so
it's like a shade look at see it's
carrying its horizon with us right with
it exactly so yes that's a good example
if you go to the horizon on your boat
and go to the horizon 20 miles away
whatever it is um and then i probably
got that number wrong and now the flat
earth people will go see you didn't know
there is a horizon whatever it is way
closer than 20 miles unless you're in a
crow's nest okay right
so you go to the horizon and you just
see ocean and you go to the next horizon
you just see ocean and that's what the
universe is like as far as we can tell
yeah i mean that's as simple as going to
the top of a hill you experience that
any time like you're driving up a hill
or on a bike you look at the top of the
hill and it just looks like that's the
end you get at the top of the hill and
it's just more of the same there's more
over here
this time you're looking down more the
same that's cool yeah all right let's go
to elaine
who said this might be the last question
we have time for okay go alain says this
hey neil chuck and professor cox uh
um
we have electron microscopes to probe
smaller stuff than with regular light
microscopes do you think somebody is
going to come up with a quark microscope
or something of that nature that will
enable us to see even smaller or get
closer to those strings
fantasize about it wow
that was this
trick let me just set that up just real
quick so regular microscopes use
visible light
and visible light has certain
wavelengths
so if you really think about it a
visible light telescope can't see
anything smaller than the wavelength of
light you're using because the light
would just wash over it and wouldn't be
able to bring it into focus so
electron microscopes
use basically i think brian is at x-rays
because electrons and x-rays are the
same thing at certain
you can you can beam electrons to have
an energy level of that of an x-ray and
x-rays has really small wavelengths yeah
so now you can see detail way smaller
than visible light so this questioner
knows this about electron microscopes
and let's take another step and there's
a really great fundamental point to make
here which goes to black hole physics
actually again
is that um so as you make um if you if
you take the weight blank down
quantum mechanics allows you to think of
light as a wave or as a stream of
particles called photons and as you
shrink the wavelength the energy of the
photon goes up so that's just basic
quantum again so the smaller the
wavelength the higher the energy
so you get to a point where if you want
to probe smaller and smaller distances
what actually happens is you make a
black hole
because you put so much energy into the
small piece of space that black hole
forms and then as you put more energy in
the black hole grows
and so um so you end up reversing
that process because because as the
black hole grows then you you you get
less and less resolution again
so there's a limit
uh
so i'll step in here because chuck
didn't
you kept talking after you said yeah
first you make the black hole and then
you continue
so you can get you put more and more
energy i'm saying this sounds dangerous
it's an in principle
oh it's a thought experiment okay the
point is that you get to a point where
if you try to cram more and more energy
into a smaller and smaller amount of
space which you have to do to see the
small thing you have to get more energy
in right the smaller wavelength because
you're using photons that are higher and
higher energy or anything yes or
anything electrons or whatever it is
yeah then then you form there comes a
point where you form a black hole
in that region i think you can't say
that because your microscope got sucked
into it
because you're dead
[Laughter]
you'll you'll have less resolution so
so so it's called now leonard suskin
writes a value so ignoring the
complications
and ignoring the complication that you'd
be dead and you've destroyed the earth
you'd have less resolution on your
microscope you wouldn't because it'd be
a tiny mine tiny black hole so you
wouldn't notice it except you'd stop
seeing
so you can't probe smaller and smaller
distances forever i think susking calls
it the uv-ir connection ultraviolet
infrared connection i think that's what
he calls it
so um but but it's a fundamental
property of the universe so black holes
stop you
from doing that going to smaller and
smaller and smaller and smaller
distances pesky black hole yes yeah and
again it's fundamental it's it's
pointing to fundamental physics so we go
all the way back to this idea of space
and time and the link to quantum
dude we gotta wrap it up there oh my
gosh let's
cover the universe here
whoa
brian this has been a delight uh how uh
i know you're active on twitter where
else are you active because you're prof
brian cox on twitter
we're all sorry yeah i'm on facebook as
well um
but um twitter is my usual mode of
mode of communication i don't know why
it's not just a habit
yeah yeah it's a habit it's quick and
quick and easy and
and and sharp and so brian always great
to see you and hear from you and we'll
connect again chuck love you man love
you too
all right neil degrasse tyson here your
personal astrophysicist as always keep
looking up
[Music]